[Music]
non Village a joke is one of the
remotest villages
of
luny the population is made up of
farmers who depend on agricultural
produce ever since the villagers
remember nus had problems with water
animals regularly contaminated the water
source and pipelines to channel water to
the agricultural Fields were rudimentary
and highly
ineffective as a result many lands were
left
uncultivated the villagers had to live
with the consequences of contaminated
scarce water
among others no showers waterborne
diseases and small production of
[Music]
vegetables
fore foreign spee spee
in the past due to water scarcity
Farmers from Jerry gwoke were mainly
growing
corn today the times of water scarcity
Are Over clean water and irrigation have
brought life to Nani thanks to a grant
better known as the capacity development
Grant provided by The Joint Support
Program through the department of local
governance
Sho is now able to grow vegetables and
thanks to the farm roads she has also
started selling them in
markets
for in 2011 The Joint Support Program
carried out trainings on sustainable
development and provided local officials
with tools to identify causes of
environmental degradation poverty and
climate change impacts
and to design long-term Solutions the
training stressed the importance of
sustainably managing natural resources
such as water or Timber and provided
practical recommendations on watershed
management and organic farming
techniques after discussions in the gwag
assembly the community decided to tackle
the water and land management problem as
a follow-up to the training a grant was
given to Nani to install an irrigation
system bring water to households and
fence the water source to prevent
contamination from
animals juring Pino is the soapa the
elected people's representative of Nani
he proudly shows the due irrigation
systems how it is allowed Reviving
fallow land and channnel water to
vegetable Gardens
the main crop in Nani was corn today the
community sees a thriving kitchen Garden
in every home with a variety of
vegetables The Joint Support Program
trainings coupled with the capacity
development Grant have demonstrated that
empowering communities and local
governments to identify causes of
environmental degradation and poverty
and to design Solutions can lead to
Fantastic results today Nani has
improved its sanitation agricultural
produce and has clean drinking water The
Village has recently been connected
through Grid electricity and will soon
be connected by a Farm Road that will
bring new economic opportunities for its
people
today several villages in Bhutan are
part of the joint Support Program
initiative to train local governments on
sustainable development and to provide
them grants to complement their
financial resources to meet Community
level needs
okay
[Music]